Attention Deficit Hyperactivity
Disorder, or ADHD, is mostly of
genetic origin. Symptoms are categorized as
inattentive or hyperactive, but people can
experience both in all sorts of forms — which
means there is a spectrum of presentations.
Lisa, a young girl who wants to become a writer,
will help us understand what it means to grow up
with ADHD. Her story shows how her atypical
brain makes it harder to achieve her dreams.
During early childhood, Lisa has a
tough time paying attention. She gets
distracted, starts daydreaming, and
frequently forgets or loses things.
Because her senses pick up too much
information for her brain to process,
she gets overwhelmed and as a result, she
often cries or becomes frustrated. Her parents,
who don’t know better, scold her instead
of helping her deal with the pain.
In primary school, Lisa can’t sit still
and often disrupts the class. She is smart,
but besides English and the arts, has
bad grades. It is not long before Lisa
is branded as lazy — as someone
who doesn't use her potential.
It’s also hard for Lisa to make friends.
She feels different and is bullied. The
few friends she has tell her that she is
too emotional, but admire her enthusiasm.
In middle school, Lisa starts doodling to help
her stay focused but her teacher doesn’t like
that and scolds her, because he thinks
she is distracted. And so she masks her
inattention and puts all her energy
into nodding and making eye contact.
But by doing so, she loses her concentration
entirely and ends up not listening at all.
This is where she turns inwards and
develops a passion for creative writing.
During high school, her mind starts
racing — with a thousand thoughts in
her head. She now wears headphones,
to isolate the noise and calm herself
down. But when she has her period
even that doesn’t help anymore and
she goes through intense mood swings. She
begins binge eating and starts smoking.
At age 19, Lisa gets into a top literature
program. But the responsibilities of everyday
life are overwhelming. She feels burned out,
stops showering, cleaning up, and going to class.
One evening, she tells her best friend that
she can’t handle it anymore. All her life she
has been too different to ever fit in. All
her life she felt like a burden to others.
Her friend tells her about a psychiatrist,
and as a last resort, Lisa goes to see her.
The psychiatrist first thinks
it's depression. But then,
asking about Lisa’s childhood and family
history, she notices something else and
requests more tests. A few weeks later,
Lisa is diagnosed with ADHD and depression.
The doctor explains to Lisa that ADHD is not
limited to the most well-known symptoms. For
example, people with ADHD also have deficits in
their executive functions, such as working memory,
time perception, or emotional regulation.
Some also get sleepy when drinking coffee!
However, they often also have higher
levels of creativity, are more caring,
and are more curious than their peers, making them
great artists or scientists. Plus, they react more
calmly to stressful situations — some become
fearless firefighters or outstanding surgeons.
The psychiatrist goes on to explain
that ADHD symptoms can be treated
with medication and therapy and that
regular sleep and exercise can help too.
When Lisa takes her first pill the next day,
she bursts into tears. For the first time
in her life, her mind is quiet. It does not
take an effort for her to get up and shower.
She realizes that, throughout her whole life,
she has spent so much energy trying to do
things that others do without even thinking.
Although medication helps, Lisa knows that
it is not enough. She has to make changes
to her life and find work that plays to
her strengths. By the time she is 30,
she learns to accept and
appreciate her neurodivergence,
and her atypical mind is celebrated
after the publication of her first novel.
What do you think? If you had - or have-
ADHD would you adapt your brain to your
life by taking pills, going to therapy, and
masking your behaviors? Or is the solution to
accept your differences and adopt a lifestyle that
fits who you are? Tell us in the comments below!
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com